hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood we
are in the middle of the day actually
let's pause let's remember where we are
we are exploring the swamp and there is
a lot of good stuff
in the swamp a lot of good stuff that i
will eventually have to sell
but for now i just need to gather it i
am starting to run out of space though
and i got a lot of these medium caliber
magazine but
nothing really to use it with yet i
probably need to push down past the rune
and go this way
they said something about there was a
quarry with the people from the village
that actually made it through the trees
which is shocking
to say the least
why are we being all dramatic this is a
weird
glenn of trees does this no there's
nothing
it's a normally creepy thing just like
everything else in this game it's just
averagely creepy weird noises and
ambience aside
i guess it's fine okay cool yeah
this is um yeah this is cool okay
it's a long stretch of nothing it's a
weirdly long stretch of nothing here if
they keep this up i'm gonna have to
return soon
hello oh what am i
mushroom glade oh
are these poisonous an intense sweet
smell of mushrooms fill the air
all right i'm not touching them
well i don't have that's the stuff i
need to burn away with a torch i don't
have a torch
i can make a torch if i find enough
stuff to make a torch but i don't have a
torch at the moment
okay oh wait maybe i can okay
that's why you'd need to burn it away
because i doubt i'm gonna be able to
make it in time if i go all the way
around here
yeah i wouldn't be able to make it in
time okay so
footsteps that's a lot of footy steppies
what the hell
footprints yeah i get that what the hell
all right hello found a house i guess
oh my god it's head-to-toe
poisonous mushrooms uh is this worth
going in here
because i'm gonna get blasted in the
face with poisonous mushrooms
i bet this is why i need that poison
cure thing
that's why i need the poison cure oh or
i could go in the window
that'd be smarter that would be much
smarter yeah
i'ma do that i'ma do that hello
anybody here more mushes
what i don't wanna know i do not
wanna know i don't wanna know hi
oh hi even the floor is made of wood it
bends up under my feet a white colorless
goose seeps from the ceiling and walls
uh mushroom granny hey oh
an old woman sits on a weathered rocking
chair her sleep is
deep and peaceful a handful of ripe
mushrooms grows
out from beneath her thick hair yeah i'm
not just gonna steal a mushroom
i'm gonna wake her like the old lady hey
how you doing
the old lady slowly opens her eyes for a
moment she stole
i don't like her eyes she stares into
space with an absent gaze finally she
becomes aware of my presence
wait you're not her empty eyes now take
on a questioning expression
i didn't expect any guests she throws a
nervous look at the door on her right
then gazes about the mushroom-infested
house
she relaxes a bit i suppose you won't
tell me what you want
and you want something since you're
standing here in front of me
point your finger at the door eat thee
that's a bit dramatic don't you think
i'll just point my finger at the door
it's a door to my chamber
there's nothing that would interest you
there the old lady puffs her cigarette
come back when you remember what it is
you want from me okay
photo of a road the old lady examines a
photo where thoughts wander far away
i remember cars driving along this road
and then they closed it they set up a
fence and a gate of both the fence
and the gate got devoured by the woods
eventually i think that's how it was
e why do you want me to eat the old lady
i'm not gonna eat the old lady why would
i eat the old lady
why would i eat the old lady why would i
do that
why would i why would you want me to eat
the old lady that shouldn't be an option
to say that right now that shouldn't be
an option on my wheel why would that be
an option
i don't want to eat the old lady okay
there's still more footprints going this
way
i'm gonna have to get back soon enough
footprints
oh thank you footprints old lady you're
in there
aren't you oh shrine
oh wow yeah mushrooms all right cool
glad i saw that um
i got a f
oh bag a bag with a missing strap
someone must have lost in recently looks
like you've been lying here for a short
while
okay a torn cigarette pack the caption
at the bottom reads
return south edge of swamp right okay
thanks for the bandage i guess south
edge of
swamp you say i gotta start getting back
soon this is um
it's getting a little too far i've got
five oh man i am far
okay cool um that's great
all right what oh this poor bastard died
of starvation sure yeah let's go with
starvation and not the forest
maliciously tore him to pieces oh hi
oh no probably died of starvation
that's definitely what happened oh and
they had metal on them
oh thank you oh
fence holes holes
holes holes
holes i don't like holes oh
i don't like holes i don't like holes at
all
i don't like those holes holes
oh this is the guy from the village it's
quite a wide tunnel there are finger
marks on the
guy from the village someone who's
inside this hole i can barely make out a
silhouette looks like a grown man with
long disheveled hair
is completely covered in mud well done
on these holes
dude really good job
you really did it your holes are uh
extravagant
is there really nothing here oh there we
go hey you don't mind if i take this
crate it's not in a hole
so uh i'm guessing it's not your
territory
oh my goodness okay thank you
uh i'm out of here you take care of
yourself
have fun digging holes and uh i will
never see you probably ever again i
guess we're heading back
i gotta go up if i find more stuff on
the way that's great if i find enemies
that's not great and then it looks like
tonight i'm gonna have a chance to use
this gun
see what it actually can do unless
something wants to give me a chance to
test it right now
this is a bad idea going in here this is
a terrible idea
oh yeah terrible idea terrible idea
terrible
terrible idea worst idea i've ever had
terrible
terrible idea horrible idea terrible i
hate this idea
i hate this oh hold it
oh really oh my god really it didn't
even kill him
freaking amazing gun oh god i thought i
reloaded
ah how do you reload this thing
how do you reload it oh my god there we
go okay and
well that was worth it there was no
point in any of this this is a terrible
idea from the get-go
so it really does take
no no no no no no
no no no no boom oh that got you
oh that got you that got you yeah take
that
swamper yeah swamper chomper swamper
yeah the cha that was no good maybe
there's something actually in there
maybe but uh honestly i don't want to
know about it and this this gun
i do not have nearly enough bullets it's
it's good i guess you know it was
ambitious to say that it would one shot
an enemy but hey it got the swamper and
that's good
in my book that's good it's a hell of a
journey just to get back
oh this place of course you know they
put the house all the way over here
what i don't remember saying a radio
time all right
just in time okay i'm gonna put away the
gun unless there's gonna be like a a
surplus of bullets down the road i'm
gonna put that away uh let me go cook
what i need to cook
all right do i get another dose not yet
not yet
not yet okay that's generally doing
plenty of gas
plenty of gas so much gas all right this
should last me through the night i think
i don't need to use it just yet
upgrade workshop absolutely now i could
make that
pump action shotgun now that sounds like
what i should make even though i did
make the shotgun the pump shotgun
that sounds like the real deal okay but
i can't do it yet i need tape and a lot
of other things
and a tube okay so i'm good on bandages
let's trade out the hunting rifle i
i don't know what takes the medium
caliber magazine but let's try the
shotgun
actually i'm going to take the shotgun
and the pistol out just in case
just in case you know how it is maybe i
should put some
gas in the generator just in case
every time every time you stupid eyeball
why not fill her up what the hell
what the hell fill her up the spur lurge
a little bit okay little splurge never
hurt nobody so let's start with the
shoddy boom banger and then
work from there don't get me wrong the
hunting rifle probably very good for
taking out things at a long range but
uh for getting up close and personal i
feel like i'm gonna need this
all right i'm feeling good
wait molotovs oh god i'm not feeling so
good molotovs molotovs molotovs molotovs
uh oh god i need more slots
all right screw the armor here we go i
can blast them out of the century
who's coming at me who's coming at me oh
my god
wait if someone comes by there
oh
oh god oh god oh god oh god what what
the hell
get the shotgun out oh come on come on
oh my god oh my god what the hell
what the hell clung clunk okay
all right that was a click that was qui
that was quick reload i blasted that
thing in the next century what the hell
happened to it
why didn't it die i guess those don't do
too much damage
i don't know i don't know oh
what the hell oh it's the the
delight okay as long as oh another one
where are you at okay yeah where are you
where where
where is it i hear it
what are you doing what is he doing
oh there it is oh
oh that's right on me hey
oh my god that's is bright
that's fine can i close that please
thank you
you coming for me because i will come
for you
oh yeah you think you think yeah come on
come on come through the comment
where are you where are you were you you
crap for
you you poop come at me
come at me oh you're what
something is out there something is
definitely out there okay i'm brave i'm
brave i'm brave
i'm brave i'm brave i'm brave
oh oh my god
where where i don't see it oh my god
boom
can't just get wrecked bomb oh reload
god damn it oh
my god it's not pumped it's not a pump
action
oh my god oh my god
oh god okay okay okay hills
pills oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god this is
terrible terrible
terrible okay reload that
reload oh my god oh my god where are you
where are you come on come on come on
come on you want some me
oh you want some of me huh
there you go that's what you get and i
get those yeah i got him in
i got him i got them all i need way more
traps
that was really tough i almost died
hello three how are you let me go gather
the things i'm going to sell to you
well let me go cook the meat first let
me turn off my generator let me do it
all
literally everything that i i meant to
do and then didn't do
in a panic almost to another dose that's
great
so shotgun pretty good reload sucks
single shot
uh not the best if i could sell that and
get a new one
i will okay see how this does first hey
how you doing you will take these and uh
good and i'll take that and that and uh
when will i be able to make a pump
action
maybe i should just get the stuff for it
double barrel sounds pretty cool
but pump action is probably what i need
i need the weird thing
and then the tape and then i'll keep it
for now
you know what actually i won't keep it
because the pistol for now it's the ammo
that i have i have ammo for the pistol
and i cannot forget that i have my melee
weapon just because i started getting
guns doesn't mean i need to use them i
should use melee for as much as possible
and traps melee and traps that's what i
need to use okay the the
tube another long barrel i'm gonna just
buy those
i need more weapon parts and tape oh my
god how much
really all right i'll see what i find
it's not like i'm gonna be able to make
it anyway
ah 450 for weapon parts my god
that's really expensive that's big
expensive
maybe the medium caliber magazine i
don't know why i have so many of those i
don't have the gun for it
i could get rid of the hunting rifle
maybe that would be good i don't
actually like the hunting rifle because
single shot
it's it's a i'm not hunting anything i'm
surviving all right i'm gonna get rid of
the hunting rifle
and i'll get the weapon part just in
case
i get what i need everyone's probably
screaming like
don't do it no please oh god no
and that's too late i did it i don't
have enough inventory space to hold all
these weapons i gotta stick to one and
that's my excuse and it's a good excuse
so
okay close to another dose okay i gotta
use my shovel this time i can't
blow my ammo let's stick to just the
pisti
for now and all the i'll i'll actually
even bring
you know what also i need a torch i
remembered that i need
a torch so i'm gonna bring a torch and
actually i'm almost out of
that ammo on that gun so i'll bring
three of these just in case i'm gonna
use my shovel don't get me wrong i'm
gonna use it
but just in case you wouldn't go into
this swamp without a gun and plenty of
ammo
so don't act like i'm weird i'm going
i'm gonna go up north i'ma skate for
that that house near the junkyard and
then i'm gonna go
westerly from there who's there
who's there oh
i hate you doc you here doc's not here
anymore oh poison antidote well it's
uh it's too late now okay got it you
doc's not there anymore that's
interesting
i have there was another long barrel
there ah
ah that's a poor guy well you know he
did he died doing what he loved
going into space you know oh god
are those more diggable
all right maybe i won't use my melee
weapon because i'm gonna spend it all on
these holes
which have whoa which have arguably very
good stuff in them that compressor i
don't know what the compressor is for
but i can fix it now so that's good
sick sweet stuff man and a mush
even better i'm gonna go on a trip
tonight i don't know if there's gonna be
oh hey bud hi
oh medium bullet that's funny i i don't
need you anymore i
sold the gun i'm actually full up again
my god
you get so much crap so much crap all
right i have to go back because i have
to drop off again
it's going to be just like come down to
me picking and choosing what i really
need
[Applause]
[Music]
jump we're good i'll take a sippy slurp
of the well
slurpedy blurpity also what's with the
door and the
the the drag marks that's probably the
bad thing
that i should be aware of antlers rag
bottle
and then oh my god i've got so much crap
i guess i should board up some windows
but not really what i was hoping to be
doing at them at this moment you know
not really the journey i thought my soul
was gonna take at this juncture
you know what i mean you picking up what
i'm putting down
i'm gonna fix the oh sorry bud i'm gonna
fix the compressor okay
repair pressure i could refill an empty
oxygen tank here
great i don't even know what the oxygen
tanks were for
yet uh this and then oh my god uh
so i'll eat it eat metal
mush i can cook this stack them
i don't need two i don't need them
the frick was that all right i'm gonna
be very picky about what i pick up
because i got plenty of valuables
it's like i don't need to pick up crap
god damn i thought i was gonna go on a
trip
but uh i don't need to pick up random
crap anymore
i need to be very selective i need ammo
that's what i need
and i need a like a teddy bear that i
could hug in the middle of the night
when things get spooky
i shouldn't repair my shovel i'm
bad at games i'm bad at remembering
important things that are gonna help me
survive all right yes the fug
hi uh alcohol and pill okay i'm gonna
take
those are the things i'm gonna take none
of those junkyard okay i need to go to
the place
north of the junkyard there's something
up there
man the fog bear trap that's useful
i'll take that the alcohol is good none
of the others don't take junk
oh hey bud no twitching is bad
twitching bad i don't trust twitching i
don't trust i don't have like anything
to test it oh twitching bad i don't
trust twitch
just in general i don't trust twitch as
an organization who trusts it no one
if i get something up here that needs me
to dig it out and i run out of shovel i
might be so mad
why we make ominous noise why you be
ominous
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
wow the window is blocked by rubble i
must find a different way inside
all right okay a bear trap
many nails and planks some useful scrap
metal gun
parts ropes tapes antlers some tools
metal
old compressor broken axe empty bottle
scrap metal and fine quality clothing oh
those are all the junk piles well i
already dug those up
that's not really helping me already i
already got those
i have enough scrap metal which i never
thought i'd say
all right this is great
i love this uh i can't see
okay so i need to get by you
oh man you i wish if i had a flare
uh flares would make that's trivial i'm
very dumb okay hey uh big snail
oh
oh hey belly the roof beneath this shell
is completely destroyed this nail shell
is probably also badly damaged maybe i
would be able to get through the
cottages with the skin on his belly
seems quite frail it looks like a human
hand but it's sticky and grown into the
shell
a key grows out of the palm i should be
able to easily tear it off
thank you thank you for that i do i
don't need to get in that badly just yet
um but i got this key that i think goes
to this door which means that i could
probably make it through this gap
through this time gated crapoloniums
you know how it'd be you know how it do
try the key
yeah buddy got the key
and i'm through why i don't know why i
came through here
seems like a bad idea to be honest
seems like grade a terrible idea where
am i
who knows oh
gross a weird pulsating gross it looks
quite delicate
oh okay
i'll whump it oh
i freed the snail oh i freed the snail
wait i freed this dale the snail was
paralyzed by some live tissue sort of an
umbilical cord to cast
oh all right i feel good about my
decision oh no
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
oh oh everything's dying oh
great great good
feel good about that i i freed it
i freed the snail you go live happy life
snail
you're welcome i guess that's just to
guard against rash action which i am not
i'm not about rash action at all
snail you oh i thought you were free
wait but i thought the journal said
it should be able to leave in peace now
is what it said and it's not
it's not leaving in peace maybe i gotta
wait a day
i don't know i'll i'll find out later i
i guess
i don't know i'll come back i think hey
how you doing
hey how you doing hey you're all quiet
now i don't know if that's good but uh
i like it mushys oh hi
um uh oh oh
uh doc you got something on your in your
face
yeah you got it this lens hides more
secrets than your little [ __ ] rat
brain is capable of understanding
the doctor digs through the mud i think
he's looking for something
deep underground there's a current of
electricity [ __ ]
electricity he starts flailing his arms
wildly
throwing pieces of mud everywhere around
him and it flows
underground from tree to tree the doctor
suddenly freezes
staring at me with his arms midair and
it powers everything
it connects it all if i had a light bulb
if i just screwed it into one of these
branches
it would light up i bet it [ __ ] would
he bends over a small hole in the mud
and continues digging
maybe this is where you're hiding maybe
this is the way okay
okay man can you hear the trees sing
they're calling us
they're showing us the way they're
showing us the way at the same blocking
it
i can't understand it he kicks a stone
are they trying to tell us something
are they putting us to a test i don't
know maybe they're lost too and don't
know what to do
he shakes his head dispirited and goes
silent after a long
pause he turns towards me his glasses
are so dirty
i barely see the eyes hiding underneath
i see you haven't regained your speech
you need to find another doctor the
doctors lost in this thought a cigarette
sticks out of his mud-covered mouth
using what remains of his shoe he draws
lines in the ground
they seem to intersect in completely
random places i'm waiting
he doesn't stop drawing he moves away
for a bit and makes a wide arc four
the doctor flicks his cigarette the dirt
stomps it and drags it on the ground
creating the last straight line
you [ __ ] drawing was never my forte i
haven't slept a wink in
many days i don't think this is good for
me i hear this voice all the time can
you hear it
her heavenly voice doctor stares right
into my eyes mud drips from his face he
hasn't blinked in over a minute
no you don't why would you you don't
know her
steps towards me and lowers voice i'm a
bit fed up with her
a bit a little tiny bit she must know
i'm heading her way
i'm doing everything i can i don't eat i
don't sleep i search under every rock
under every [ __ ] bush she must
understand it
she must give me some time some little
time off tell her this will you
okay uh yeah wait what do you have to
trade again uh what uh
uh oh weapon parts hey that's a steal
man
i'll take that that's a good deal thanks
see you around i don't know man i don't
know
it's almost time to head back but let me
just go a little bit more to the left
see what's up hello hundreds of dead
insects lie scattered around the body
but they didn't just die here someone
had carefully prepared the scene
a giant dead centipede has been placed
on the dead man's face along with his
nose
terrible horrible why i i don't care i
don't know
it it's bad that's bad stay away from it
oh mike oh my god it's everything i
would ever
what the frick what the freak i will
kill you i will kill you i will oh my
god oh my god
get my gun my gun my gun shoot it
shoot it oh my god my gun
hate that hate that but this is
apparently the chest man i didn't need
to buy
dick i didn't need to buy diddly i need
to buy nothing i just need the thing
that's going to help me
upgrade this crap that's all i need i
need the uh what
oh my god oh my god i hate
you a lot
all right i don't need the meat i mean i
i have mushrooms so i think that'll be
enough oh hi
uh the bear trap yeah you know bear trap
is gonna be good
whoa hey bud let me just see what's in
here
nothing great good uh that was useful
thank you good luck pick use okay i'm
back home
all right let's uh set out these bear
traps uh i'm just gonna put it right in
this doorway
number one because obviously if
something comes in here i would like it
to be
snapped um and actually at the same time
uh let's put one right here fence build
do i wanna why would i build the
is it really gonna help i don't know if
that's gonna help they would just climb
over it right
i don't know anyway just one right here
at the juncture where they could come in
excellent excellent i'ma load this place
to the tits with bear traps
maybe right here and then i can blow it
up that'd be cool
yeah you ain't getting in this way
that's for damn sure
and then right in this gap okay tonight
i'm not gonna be caught with my pants
down i'm gonna be caught with my pants
up i'm gonna have pants
let's go ahead and oh let's go ahead and
cook let's cook the stuff
it's a lot of good stuff delicious
oh there i go uh deal double damage
and become invisible if i stay still you
know at night that might be
pretty ah yeah i gotta use my abilities
at night why am i not
doing that i'm so dumb
i don't plan to get close to death so
i'm gonna go with chameleons so that i
might be able to
survive oh really i can't inject any
more essence
are you sure about that are you sure
because i'm pretty sure i could shove
more in
i'm pretty sure i could well all right
then i never need to gather
mush again which is interesting we got
board and nails oh weapon parts
too many weapon parts okay oh too much
alcohol
all right there's one more thing i want
to board up just before things
this this is what i wanted to board up
definitely yeah
maybe this door i don't like that this
store is kind of open
okay let's do this oh repair my
gosh darn shovel okay
okay who's gonna get freaking god
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] are you
give me one good reason why i shouldn't
kill you
hello mute oh no
something is lurking in the shadows
oh
oh i'm sorry from beneath the mask you
can hear a horribly distorted
resounding voice of a child very sorry i
didn't know you were living here
the figure tries to turn its head but
its enormous neck makes this task
impossible do it complete
i didn't want to disturb you mister i
just wanted to hide i don't know this
part of the woods everything here is
different and this wee hud here seems so
cozy and safe
please let me stay please don't chase me
off i've got nowhere to go
the villagers don't allow me to live in
the camp i promise i won't
play anymore i'll be quiet you can cover
me with something if you don't want to
look at me
please just let me stay oh man
okay yeah you can stay is is it you
recently i've grown quite a bit my mom
always used to say i needed to be big
and strong to help her out in the field
the boy tries to hug his frails knees
with the disproportionately massive
torso
but i i don't want to be big anymore
it's very hard being big
you need to be so so strong to even walk
now my violin is too small for me oh no
someone killed our village sao the
mother of all pigs
the villagers cried after her a lot they
said there must be food on the other
side
they cut through the trees with their
axes they barely managed to the trees
kept growing back
i followed them but they didn't let me
stay in their camp the boy adjusts the
crack
mask with his overgrown hand i wanted to
go back home but a huge hole appeared
where the passage used to be when the
ground shakes
holes like these sometimes appear the
villagers said it's the woods being
angry i've run to the swamp and that's
how i found your home
it's a very beautiful house much more
beautiful than the villagers camp
they sleep on rocks i think it's some
kind of quarry
okay you can stay yeah okay
just please don't mutate into an even
more full
horrible monster and come attack me
it's not safe um
hey you know i could stay in there i
wouldn't mind this
this is nice hey we could stay hunkered
up together for the night
that'd be cool would you like that buddy
you and me
chilling out i could put a light in here
we could talk the night away
so how's the music coming along
good hey great talking to you man
hey cheer up bucko you're doing great
you're gonna be in an orchestra someday
you really got a talent for it
keep practicing maybe like tonight's a
special night and nothing's gonna attack
or something because it is awfully nice
to have like a metal door
i don't know if it's something that
would actually keep anything out
i haven't heard anything hit my bear
traps ashley seems like a pretty quiet
night all things considered
oh never mind i had to say something
i don't i no no i'm good i'm okay
i'm all right thank you but no thank you
thank you but no thank you thank you no
thank you no thank you to the thank you
thank you but no thank you i'm okay just
me and the musician
music man boy music boy
music boy
beautiful yes wonderful
so good uh
hey you still here there buddy you can
stay you know
you you can stay i'm glad that you're
back
me too all right you you you stay safe
you stay safe and well
oh my ass all right hey buds uh i gotta
you gotta take some of this stuff
because i
i don't need nearly any of this stuff
that i have
the mushrooms i don't need anymore fire
axe i don't use
for some reason i don't know why it says
a formidable weapon
i don't know god i wish i could upgrade
my storage on the workbench
i guess i could put stuff here in the
wardrobe that might help
i also could put the wood yeah i don't
know why i don't just keep the wood
in the saw okay the wood will go here
and the nails okay that helps tube
magazine i only need one i only need
one more of those technically i only
need one if i'm gonna go for the pump
okay let's sell these things tick tick
tick tick tick
uh take all that and i'll take tick tick
i'll take all that
this thank you all right i'm gonna try
to find where this villager is
before i end this episode because i i
feel like i just gotta go
to it i just gotta go so i'm just gonna
go
oh
i found the ruin
would it even be remotely worth it
coming in here
oh my god oh my god okay
i'm going to carefully navigate through
here
and i'm not going to wake a single one
of these things
oh oh
let me put on my oh
oh okay all right
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneaky
[Music]
okay i don't need gas i don't need i
need bread or gas
oh maybe i need gas a little bit i don't
know
oh this door seems to be blocked from
the other side then why
would i come in here why did i come in
here
it was just blocked from the other side
[Music]
okay okay okay okay okay okay
uh you know what actually why why would
you open that way
open towards me what what are you doing
oh you know what actually that's fine
i don't care i think i saw an explody
barrel
up here what if i just shoot that what
would that do
would that blow a hole in it
oh god oh god
oh god
well that opened the door all right i'm
gonna chuck a molotov in there
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go here we go here we go
one yep burn it yep
yep oh yipes oh yep oh yeah it's no no
no no
okay it's dead
oh that's not good well this is a
dangerous game
oh craw there's more than one another
molotov here we go
two for one baby yes three front oh my
god there's three oh my god oh god okay
okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay i see where you okay oh god
you're not dead
oh god ring around the rosie okay pocket
full of posey ah
i thought i got you i thought i would
have got you
no you missed i missed i missed you
okay and then you slappers all right
i'm gonna eat this pill actually which i
should be doing so that my lungs can
work more
efficiently okay is that all the
problem ones okay that's all the
problems
oh i thought for sure that would have
been
all that for nothing then all that for
nothing
oh oh oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god okay i saw another
exploding barrel
you know i don't know what that did i
would have thought that it would
they would have ripped through that door
but apparently no here we go
and yucca ah i missed one i missed one i
definitely missed one
oh yeah i missed one come here you come
come come come on come on
come on come on come on oh yeah you
scared huh
what did he walk through the fire is he
just burning alive he's just burning
alive
oh god oh god oh god ah yeah got one of
them
okay and the other one
all right and then
that's why i got the shovel for the
reach baby for the reach
all right did that no i just still
didn't open the game well there was no
point in that and i killed them all well
good great girl i said all morning doing
that
but for a good reason too just to show
how badass i am just so i'll show what a
boss
that's what i am i gotta go to this
quarry that's what i gotta do
oh there we go all right that's fun
cool all right those aren't so bad those
aren't so bad
i mean oh god i mean they're all bad but
at least that one's
somewhat manageable hey bud you got any
ammo on you
nope thanks you know actually i'm gonna
take this thank you
i need to run okay if i'm hearing a
chicken that means there's gotta be like
the chicken lady nearby or something i
don't know ooh
okay oh no no no no no no no no no no
no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
is it over here where is it oh my
i'm completely on the wrong side of the
map i'm trapped out in
no man's land and it's getting close to
the time when i need to start going back
oh hey how are you doing alcohol
okay i did the pill yeah up here please
please up here oh what is this what is
this shiny stone
cool great what is this what is this
what is this what is this why do i care
about this
oh hi oh hey bud uh oh okay uh um
uh interesting about that uh whoa god
please don't
oh god what stop stop stop being
anything
oh yeah fight each other fight each
other okay
all right okay yeah yeah yeah yeah you
run
you run you run i don't know what you
were doing in here
probably hiding from me i'm gonna eat
this bread
all your bread is mine i'm searching
your crate where's this cory
where is the goddamn cory a shiny stone
thank you i need
ammo not just stone uh lantern i guess
that's good yeah sure i'll take that
where's this quarry i need ammo another
shiny stone i don't need chinese stone
i don't need to sell anything i have so
much thing
where's the quarry
wreckage wreckage of what wreck what
wreckage
wreckage of who and what what wreck oh
what the hell oh
i won't be able to swim through this
patch with it ah that's why i need
anoxia
that it all makes sense now it all makes
sense ah
smart smart hey how you doing okay
i'm gonna kill you oh yeah yeah yeah
weird
oh sorry that was my bed okay hang on
hang on
i don't like whatever that was what just
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh no not here no no no
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh i need
pills
put pills in me what bells at me what
feels in me
go shoot
that thing reload oh my god reload
oh my god what happened where'd it go
ush
oh my god reload damn it oh where'd it
go
oh no
oh my god i hate you i hate you and
you're gonna crawl out of there
anyway hey look at that yeah that's
that's fun hey look at you
hey cool this is it's good stuff um
the wreckage i didn't see a wreckage am
i in the wrong place was query like up
here or something or was it down here i
what i have to do now is i have to make
a mad dash as fast as i can
and hope that i make it back home in
time but i'm going to save that to the
next episode so i am not going to worry
about that right now
that is a problem for future me so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye